Kevin Costner good morning welcome
thanks for being here this is your first
TV series and I read that you thought
initially it would just be one season so
successful it's now in its second yeah
it's like I was raised in like a cave or
something
keep going or something like that yeah
why was it important for you to cover
the struggles of ranchers in the modern
West I didn't think of it in that way I
mean I I try to put the audience on my
shoulder the first time I read this
script because you go to the TV you go
to the movies for something you know the
lights go out you want to just be
transported and so when I read a script
all of a sudden I feel myself being
transported and suddenly we're in the
Bitterroot Valley the same Valley that
that Lewis and Clark went down and and
people are reminded once again when they
watch that these places still exist I
you know we can we can get caught up in
what we do but you know
an incredible amount of History went
down out there I don't think we ever
tired seeing running rivers and valleys
and mountains and if you can set up
drama against all that it's fine I think
we set a girl boy movie against minor
league baseball in Bull Durham it's fun
yeah yeah when you hear about actors
doing westerns you often hear a
backstory usually a humorous backstory
about how they had to learn how to ride
wasn't a problem for you though you were
already Road did you have to learn
anything new yeah no well there's a lot
listen I I I'm okay I'm okay right I
work around people who are really good
with horses but it's something I wanted
it's something I've done since I was
little wanted to do uh and I think
everybody and I think that's one of the
joys when you go to the movies who
wouldn't want to run with the Buffalo
and I just don't like necessarily giving
that up to stunt man I want to do as
much as I can although you know I I have
stopped man were you able to do most of
it I I yeah and that that movie I did
pretty yeah most of it yeah exactly
that's that's yeah in certain instances
you just have to you know
it's the fun of doing movies who doesn't
want to get to Kiss the Girls save the
day you know climb the building and you
know turn off the bomb we're happy to
say that Luke Grimes and Kelsey asbell
are here in the studio welcome
because I want to know what this ride is
like for you because it started as a
sleeper hit and now it is ginormous
start us off Kelsey about how you're
processing it you too Luke oh it just
means to you I don't think we have
processed it really it's it's wild
yeah I mean it's it's this has been a
life-changing job and experience I think
but you know we both feel really lucky
to be a part of it and and really love
making it so does it feel different
making it after it blows up right
because you do season one it gets
renewed season two and then it's popular
it gets renewed and then it really takes
off during the pandemic and now you got
14 million views for the trailer trailer
in like half a day right I mean does
that change the feeling of going and
acting and doing the job
I guess it just changes the airport
experience that way there everything
else kind of feels the same time
the haircuts hope so that is funny the
airport experience but you know at the
end of season four Luke you you went
away for self-reflection he came back
Kelsey and he says I see the end of us
it was that was Heavy that was very
heavy yeah and you were known as a very
emotional character you are not a crybab
cry baby man thank you but but you tend
to be a little emotional in in your
scene sure yeah I mean uh it's it's sort
of part of where he's at right he's
always kind of between this rock and a
hard place and between his dad and his
wife that's sort of his his storyline
his Arc what decisions he gonna make and
I can't wait to find out either yeah we
sorry you started out both of you as
like Romeo and Juliet I know people have
said that but that makes me nervous
because Romeo and Juliet has a really
really sad and tragic ending I hope I'm
not giving anything away
um and you guys are tested almost all
the jump yeah
yeah I mean well now we're in a survival
movie it's really um yeah it's Against
All Odds but I feel like this season it
really it kind of redefines our
relationship to the family and and our
part and its Legacy
absolutely yeah uh Luke the they're kind
of two kinds of people in Hollywood
right they're people who like watching
their own stuff right and there are
people who've never seen themselves for
whatever reason they don't do it you're
of the I don't watch myself variety is
that true and why it's less about not
watching myself it's more about I really
want to enjoy this whole series one day
when I'm not doing it anymore and I feel
like if I watch it now it's just gonna
get me in my head I'm gonna be judging
what I'm doing I'm not going to be able
to enjoy the story so I feel like one
once I'm totally done with this and I
can put it away years later I'll sit
down and really be able to enjoy it is
that your approach to all things that
you're in
no I mean sometimes I have to watch
things at premieres so I've seen enough
I've seen enough to know what I do so
I'm good I'm good interesting and Kelsey
what I think is so great about your
characters that you grew up on an Indian
Reservation that's a lot of the conflict
between the duttons and the Indian
reservation and you say that these are
important stories to tell yeah of course
I mean I think the Western genre you
know we're really used to The Good the
Bad and yes of course no one's ugly on
the Yellowstone but I think that um I I
offer exhibit right exactly
but no I think what Taylor Sheridan does
so beautifully is he puts two groups of
people in conversation with each other
and and uses the entertainment medium to
really talk about issues especially
native issues that matter yeah it's an
important you know one of the things I
love about the show and I'm I've watched
every episode uh multiple times I'll
actually spin off
um it's that it doesn't shy away from
the important issues I think it would be
easy as you say to sort of present good
versus evil or good and bad but it does
there it shows that there are Shades
even when people do horrible things on
the show
you kind of understand it looks like
yeah here it's good I'm gonna watch it
one day yeah yeah I can't wait
I have no idea what you're talking about
I think that's kind of the beauty of it
right there's no there's no good guy
there's no bad guy there's no villain
and I think that's just really good
storytelling and at any point someone
can can can do something wrong and also
be righteous and you're trying to figure
out like who does deserve this and
what's going on here yeah I do find
myself going back and forth but you like
it so much you've moved to Montana Mr
Grimes I have yeah it's hard to spend
that much time there and not fall in
love with it I mean as she knows I mean
we're there you know four or five months
out of the year and I just then going
back to LA felt very strange and I had
to move up there so all right I like The
Good The Bad and nobody's ugly as a yeah
bless you of the Set uh Luke Grimes uh
that's very true very true thank you
both very much